Roseanne Barr told a joke in poor taste
about an ex-government aid and so within
five seconds ABC has canceled one of the
most popular shows in the country we
will explain why the left pounced we
will analyze the fake outrage and where
the problem really lies meanwhile
nuclear talks with North Korea proceed
apace everything is tickety-boo so we
just have to make up reasons to be all
upset and angry and then Carol Markowitz
stops by to discuss why New York
Democrats are especially corrupt and
best news of all you might not be able
to tell but I did survive in my bachelor
party
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
I know what you're thinking you're
looking at me right now you say gosh
Michael looks like a swollen sweaty
boozy smoky hollow husk of a man but
that shirt looks really nice I know
that's that's how I feel just terrible
after my bachelor party
except for my chest my torso feels
really nice because I'm wearing Peter
Millar and I have to thank Peter Millar
a wonderful new sponsor and I got to
tell you like the best clothes ever they
are so so good
Peter Millar was founded in 2001 with a
single cashmere sweater it's grown into
a premium American lifestyle brand
featuring a wide range of casual
sportswear tailored menswear luxury
performance golf apparel and that part
is really important so I really have to
tell you you know that Ben hasn't paid
me ever but I do get some freebies
sometimes from the sponsors Peter Millar
is legitimately my favorite clothing
company now it is so so good right now
I'm wearing a sports shirt I'm wearing
one of the Peter Melora sports shirts
yeah the only way to describe it is to
think sort of like what golf clothing is
like because it's so soft it's so it
fits so nicely but if you're like me
we're gonna be talking about certain
heritable qualities on this show and bad
jokes about it
for me being of Italian descent we get a
little sweaty
we get you know we perspire a little bit
and the these clothes are amazing for
that it you don't really see anything
you feel really good I was wearing the
shorts all over the weekend they're just
really superb quality the polo shirts
are really really nice everything is
easy to take care of out of the dryer
you don't have to put an iron to them
I've been traveling you know for the
last few days and I pull it out the way
that I packed like most men is I crumple
it up into the tiniest ball I can and
shove it into a some crevice of my
suitcase you take it out it is great you
don't have to iron them so nice so the
sport shirt that I'm wearing is
definitely the most comfortable one that
I've ever worn I can say that about
everything I've worn from Peter Miller
right now you can head over to Peter
Moeller comm slash cough fa CoV f EF e
check out some of my Peter Millar
favorites be sure to use my link you
will receive complimentary shipping and
a
we hat that's very important that is
Peter Millar M IL l AR comm / co FFA Co
V Fe Fe Peter Miller calm / Co FFA I
tell you I am really particular about
the clothing I wear this place cannot be
beat Peter Moeller comm / co f-- fa ok i
wanted to get into some of the racial
stereotypes and pour jokes
by talking about Peter Millar because
we've got to talk about today is
Roseanne Barr this is breaking news it
just happened not 20 minutes ago
ABC News has canceled Roseanne's mega
super hit revival of her sitcom they
cancelled it because Roseanne told a bad
joke that was in poor taste and had a
racial component on Twitter and so they
cancelled it instantaneously it was so
so fast now what was the joke she told a
joke about Valerie Jarrett an
ex-government aide the response was
swift it happened immediately now
they're all out of work meanwhile do you
remember Kathy Griffin held up Donald
Trump's bloodied head in that joke that
was also in poor taste but it took a
long time for her to you know people
turn they did she lose her job should
she still go on CNN the question is why
is Kathy Griffin a c-list comedian on
CNN to begin with oh right because their
fake news Michelle wolf insulted the
appearance of Sarah Sanders the sitting
press secretary at the White House
Correspondents Dinner to her face
everyone's defending her on the left
everyone's defending Kathy Griffin on
the left Kathy both of whom were
unapologetic by the way both of them are
currently unapologetic about their jokes
Roseanne apologized right away she knew
that she crossed the line as she knew
the joke what was weak it was mean it
wasn't nice and nevertheless they
canceled her really quickly ABC wrote
quote Roseanne's Twitter statement is
abhorrent repugnant and inconsistent
with our values and we have decided to
cancel her show so what I'm gonna do
here is attack the left and the
immediacy of this response the way that
they responded to this but I have to be
crystal clear these days because the
left is so ready to pounce that's kind
of the point of this show today they're
so they're looking for anything things
are going so so well in this country
they need anything to try to attack the
even if it's minor even if it's a
misdirection or whatever but I want to
be crystal clear I am NOT defending the
joke it was not a good joke it was mean
it was in poor taste I am NOT defending
the joke oh but what what was so wrong
about the joke we'll analyze that we'll
see why it failed why it was weak and
why the left I think it's disingenuous
as they're attacking it so okay let's
weave weave intro'd this enough what did
Rosanna say Rosanna told this joke quote
because it was in a tweet so it's not
terribly grammatical but this is it
Muslim Brotherhood and Planet of the
Apes had a baby equals VJ and VJ is
standing for Valerie Jarrett you're not
doubled over guffawing with laughter of
course not it's not a very good joke
you're not I don't think anybody is
saying AHA right just a not a good joke
is in poor taste and she apologized
immediately she said quote I apologize
to Valerie Jarrett and to all Americans
I am truly sorry for making a bad joke
about her politics and her looks I
should have known better forgive me my
joke was in bad taste she tweeted that
out immediately she didn't not like some
of these other comedians on the left or
on the who you know takes them days to
even sort of apologize or in Kathy
Griffin's case she unapologetically and
she was right to do it because the joke
was not good so now we have to ask
ourselves is this apology legitimate did
she really mean what she said or does
Roseanne Barr just hate black people
just want to discriminate against black
people should really hate them which is
the more likely scenario 100% of people
think it is the former nobody was I
think Roseanne cast a black child to
play her granddaughter on the revival of
Roseanne I don't think that root I don't
think she's out there with the tiki
torches and the pointy white hats I
don't think she has racial animus I
think she told a bad joke but isn't that
legitimate does anybody out there
seriously believe that Roseanne is this
angry bitter vicious
anti-black racist who wants to bring
back Jim Crow and snow nobody believes
that but we all have to pretend that now
because things are going too well in the
country and rosy and had a show she had
the audacity to vote for Donald Trump so
they got to take her down they got to
hit anyone even vaguely associated with
Trump to understand this joke we will
analyze this joke very precisely and why
Roseanne shouldn't have her entire life
ruined because of it but why the left is
going after it before we do that we have
to explain who is Valerie Jarrett people
don't know a lot about her Valerie
Jarrett had the ear of Barack Obama for
his entire two terms in the White House
she was a senior senior advisor she was
very close to the Obamas but we don't
know a lot about her well I do but
that's cuz I took five minutes to google
it most people don't know a lot of
better so she's a senior advisor she was
the co-chairman of the obama-biden
transition team she helped set up
everything in this White House and the
first part of the Roseanne joke which is
not being talked about is linking
Valerie Jarrett to the Muslim
Brotherhood why is it not being talked
about is they can't refute that charge
Valerie Jarrett a senior senior advisor
to Barack Obama does have ties to the
Muslim Brotherhood and she has ties to a
lot of radical extreme leftist groups
what are those well judicial watch that
wonderful government watched Jo dog was
able to get files from the FBI that show
that Jarrett's father that her maternal
grandfather and her father-in-law were
all hardcore communists they were under
FBI surveillance why is that well
Valerie Jarrett's father dr. James
Bowman he corresponded and communicated
with and spoke to a paid Soviet agent
Alfred Stern half a century ago and this
guy Stern was indicted we know this guy
was a Soviet agent Bowman then moved to
Iran for work in the 1950s that's where
Valerie Jarrett was born our juror was
born in Iran her maternal grandfather a
Robert Roshan Taylor also had business
ties to that Soviet agent Stern and so
should they they all moved around DC
Chicago Iran I don't know which place is
worse I don't know it's I mean is that
the axis of evil no that's to me
not nice enough that's just a joke I'm
just telling a joke don't cancel my ABC
sitcom for that so Valerie Jarrett her
father-in-law vernon jarrett is a
big-time chicago communist he was
considered by the FBI we know from these
documents to be a potential communist
saboteur Jarrett has ties along with our
President to Frank Marshall Davis well
known communists and Jared has ties to a
lot of Muslim Brotherhood linked
organizations just a brief overview what
is the Muslim Brotherhood that phrase
gets thrown around a lot what do they
actually want to do what do they want to
accomplish the Obama administration
tried to convince us that the Muslim
Brotherhood is this moderate these are
the good guys these are the Reformers
they're not we know from a 1991
memorandum from the Egyptian Muslim
Brotherhood the group's stated goal is
quote eliminating and destroying Western
civilization from within these are the
ties to the senior advisor of the
president before we get into more of
that and why the left is reacting to
this Roseanne Barr joke in the way that
it is we have to think Lending Club
Lending Club they're they're allowing us
to go through all of this because you're
not gonna see this on Twitter you're not
going to hear this today what it's all
gonna be little clips on news shows
saying racist racist raise it mean mean
you know anti Trump whatever but we're
gonna go into it and we have to thank
one of our sponsors Lending Club Lending
Club is really really good we all need a
helping hand sometimes whether it's
unexpected repairs medical expenses or
credit card debt sometimes a little
money can make a big difference and you
can get that at Lending Club com through
a series of unfortunate events when I
was in my teenage years I came to
briefly owned my home and I've got to
tell you the thing with homes is they're
just money pits and especially when you
don't have cash on hand that roof is
gonna need repair the boiler is going to
go the heat or all that sometimes you
need a little money to get you through
in a pinch Lending Club gives you access
to low rates on loans of up to four
hundred and forty thousand dollars for
almost any purpose you can take control
of your debt finance a major purchase
make those home improvements it is
easier than going to the bank offers
much lower rates of interest then those
high interest credit cards don't put
these big expenses on
my interest credit cards there is a
better way don't be foolish with your
money just go to Lending Club commenter
how much money you need and see if
you're approved in minutes pick the
offer that is right for you and money
can be in your account in a matter of
days for more than 10 years Lending Club
has served millions of people and helped
them with over 30 1 billion dollars in
loans take charge of your finances today
with a Lending Club go to Lending Club
comm / Knowles kanto wles check your
rate for free this will not impact your
credit score you can go check your rate
right now go to Lending Club com /
Knolls KO wles
Lending Club com / Knolls keno wles
all loans made by webb bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender ok now back to
Roseann second factor Valerie Jarrett
first so that is Valerie Church he has
these connections to the Muslim
Brotherhood and that was part of
Roseanne's attempted joke so even even
early on in the Obama administration
2009 the Obama administration chose
Ingrid Madson who's a leader of a Muslim
Brotherhood linked group the Islamic
Society of North America to give a
prayer at that inauguration but what did
they do after that Barak Obama sent
Valerie Jared this senior adviser to be
the keynote speaker at an isn a national
conference linked to the Muslim
Brotherhood after that Barack Obama
tapped Arif Ali Khan to be assistant
secretary for policy development at the
Department of Homeland Security he did
that two weeks after Ali Khan
participated in a fundraiser for the
Muslim Public Affairs Council which is
another admittedly Muslim Brotherhood
linked group documents from that group
the Muslim Public Affairs Council admit
to following immediately in the
footsteps of the founder of the Muslim
Brotherhood and being linked to that
organization - so that is Valerie
Jarrett that now that we have that lets
get to the joke Roseanne's joke has two
components to it
one is ideological one is racial in
Roseanne's apology she said I'm sorry
for joking in this way about Valerie
Jarrett's politics and race the you know
wasn't nice and I'm sorry but Rosanna
because she constructed the joke because
it was an attempt at a joke
there are these two aspects to it the
Muslim Brotherhood line and then the
eight ply the Planet of the Apes line an
example of this joke if you were to make
this joke about little old me for
instance you could say William F Buckley
Jr and a bottle of Bertolli extra virgin
had a baby
m'kay right though that is the exact
parallel of that joke
you have the ideological component and
then you have this racial component
because I don't know maybe you're very
naive and young and idealistic and pure
but Italian people are sometimes
compared to olive oil now what's
interesting is that the left only takes
issue with the racial part here they
don't they're not attacking her for
saying how dare you same Valerie Jarrett
is related to the Muslim Brotherhood
because the one the racial joke is just
a very basic low-hanging racial joke but
the ideological joke is real is I think
more interesting right it's about what
Valerie Jarrett thinks which she
believes she's accusing her of having
relations with this extremist Muslim
group at that part they can't attack
because it's true so I think they know
that they okay we're not gonna get that
one let's hit her with the with the
lower hanging racist line so the left
pounced immediately Joe Scarborough
right after this comes out Joe
Scarborough goes hey ABC Roseanne
compared Valerie Jarrett to an ape there
is no apology she can make that
justifies ABC turning the blind eye to
this bigotry by airing another second of
her show even in the age of Trump these
are red lines that can never be crossed
al Sharpton you knew al Sharpton was
gonna get on the scene I'm surprised a
sharp sand didn't start tweeting about
this before it even happened Sharpton
tweets out quote the comparison by
Roseanne Barr on ABC of former Obama at
Valerie Jarrett to an ape is racist and
inexcusable ABC must take action now
then another one to Ray McKesson who
came to prominence as an activist during
the black lives matter moment he tweeted
out quote ABC how desperate are you to
profit from Roseanne's racism we know
racism cells in this country it always
has but you don't have to participate in
it this apology is meaningless cancel
Roseanne and this is an important charge
because DeRay McKesson is saying
apology is BS I won't accept your
apology I think it's fake
I think it's fraudulent I'm not gonna do
it what happens ABC immediately cancels
Roseann immediately there has there been
a board meeting have they been talking
to Roseanne's agents or looking into
this or looking into Roseanne's history
no cancelled immediately and that's the
problem here because I am NOT defending
the joke I'm just comparing the
treatment that Roseann got for making a
joke and poor taste about aspects of
people's identity and that maybe offend
a lot of people or go over the line or
whatever I'm comparing that to so many
other comedians who have gotten way
better treatment actually here's the
great example of this this happened 25
minutes ago because politics at this
point is beyond parity we have we have
superseded parity Andrea Mitchell of NBC
thought it would be a good idea to
interview one of the NBC contributors
about this whole dust-up on someone
making offensive comments about broad
groups of people on social media and on
the Internet
who does she ask joy Reid to take a look
it's hard to believe but Roseanne Barr
and she has been tweeting Regis things
but she tweeted about the Obama
administration and Valerie Jarrett and
made a really horrendous comment about
Valerie Jarrett Muslim Brotherhood in
Planet of the Apes had a baby
VJ meaning Valerie Jarrett now she has
apologized to Valerie Jarrett and to all
Americans saying I am truly sorry for
making a bad joke about our politics and
her looks I should have known better
forgive me my joke was in bad taste I
mean what do you have to do on social
media to get fired from a top-rated show
on an on an American broadcast network
I'll rephrase then what do you have to
do on social media to get fired from an
American broadcast network just to
remind you because I know politics move
so fast these days that you've probably
forgotten about the news cycle of a week
ago joy Reid was just discovered to have
made a ton of very offensive tweets
about broad groups of people on social
media years ago on her
she tweeted out she accused a gay men of
all wanting to all being sexually
attracted to young teenage boys said oh
yeah everybody knows this about gay men
they all want to have sex with young
teenage boys she tweeted out homophobic
is the term that's being used anti-gay
slurs anti gay accusations anti-gay
jokes right all over her social media
and then it was discovered and then you
know what she did she lied about it she
said oh no I don't I don't remember
doing that no I think I was hacked by
the way when someone says they were
hacked for something they said or did
that's how you know they did it that's
the Anthony Weiner rule you know you
know that she did it
joy read actually did all of this and
what happened did even MSNBC which is
left of Lennon they said oh no we don't
need to fire her
no you know hey look she made these
horribly offensive comments just a
little while ago but you know it's we'll
give her the benefit of the doubt
Roseanne makes an offensive joke a bad
joke joke and poor taste immediately
canceled massive ratings immediately
canceled so okay
Roseanne was right to apologize sure I
actually don't think people understand
why this joke was in bad taste why it
was right to apologize before we explain
the joke for all of the humorless left
because the defining feature of the left
in the Trump era is its humorless 'no
splain the bad joke and why the joke was
bad which is different than why they
think the joke was bad I got to talk
about man crates let me listen you've
you all know about man crates I love it
I got some for Christmas they're great I
use my whiskey appreciation said I use
it well since it was my bachelor party
this weekend all the time but they have
a lot of great stuff too cigar humidor
and all that here's the problem with
Father's Day Father's Day is coming up
your father's not gonna tell you what to
get him you're gonna say hey Dad what do
you want for Father's Day so I don't get
me anything nothing I don't want
anything come on truth is he might not
know what he wants reasonable he just
doesn't want to tell you he doesn't you
know he's a man what does he what does
he you don't want to say well get me
this shirt Oh get me this jacket now and
you don't want to just get him some like
boring tie from the store down the
street or something like that
Father's Day give your father a gift
that he
guaranteed to love with man crates
hand-picked and packaged gifts for every
type of dad so much of a gift is about
the experience of it what it says about
the giver what it says about the
relationship of the giver to the
receiver that's a lot of gifts we don't
really need a ton of stuff in this
culture we're a very prosperous culture
we all have basically everything that we
need we have got a little magical
devices that we keep in our pockets and
take us everywhere we want to go you
know but the experience of giving a gift
and receiving a gift is really special
so you use man crates you get the knife
making kit for the hands on dad the
whiskey appreciation crate for fathers
who like the finer things most of the
gifts ship in a sealed wooden crate with
a crowbar so you're giving your father
and experience you get to pry that man
crate open in front of everyone when was
the last time you gave your gift
something that had to be opened with a
crowbar probably not that last tie you
gave him for Christmas with man crates
you're giving to add more than a gift
you're giving him a gift experience
unlike any other comes with a 100%
satisfaction guarantee get your special
Father's Day discount today at man
crates calm / Knowles ke o WL e s like
Beyonce this is a limited time offer
only for Father's Day go there today man
crates dot-com / Knowles Keo wles man
crates calm / Knowles and you will get
that special Father's Day discount
you'll help us keep the lights on you'll
give your father a gift these guaranteed
1000% to love so why is this joke so bad
from Roseann so it's the racial
component there is this racial component
now what about that is so bad well all
racial jokes of this quality they all
attempt to portray people as animals or
uncivilized or unconscious so it
basically all the jokes play on taking a
human being less consciousness and
saying you're not really conscious you
are like a brute you're you know so for
black people who have dark skin a racial
joke along that line we'll compare them
to an animal that has dark skin but you
know this trope is existed in in other
places too in Black Panther in the the
comic book in the movie Black Panther
there's a character mbaku and what his
other name is man ape they're drawing
that parallel right because he's this
Bru
you know adversarial character these
jokes exist for other races too this
isn't just a line of joking for black
people now I'll use the race that can
constitutes my own ethnic heritage so
that I don't get rose and so that I
don't get it somehow ABC is gonna fire
me ABC you haven't employed me well yeah
okay you're getting fired anyway so for
an Italians you you hear the turtle just
use the term [ __ ] you ever hear
that for Italians so what is this for it
well it's saying southern Italians are
they're less refined they're their
brutal they're more like an animal
they're unhygenic they're covered in
grease they don't shower they're not
aware of themselves they're not aware of
how you know brutal they are so they
can't take care of it
another one used in Italy Estero Nant
which is comes from the land right
he's a tiller of the land he's a laborer
he only works with his hands he can't
work with his head that's what a lot of
these go to and now well here's another
one you ever hear the term honky that's
used for white people honky it doesn't
just come from nowhere I know that's a
little it evokes this image of a car
horn or something when it comes from
it's actually in Hungarian insult it's
an insult from the mispronunciation of
honky from Hungarians and it's referring
to Hungarian laborers manual laborers
who don't work with their minds work
with their hands all of them Roseanne's
Planet of the Apes reference [ __ ]
[ __ ] is an Italian one hunger you know
hunky from your hands all of them just
mock the lack of consciousness now why
is it important because with Valerie
Jarrett it came out of nowhere it so
Valerie Jarrett is this very
sophisticated woman you might despise
her politics she might have radical ties
but she is this a very intelligent woman
she the joke just isn't funny it that
her race is not central to what's funny
about Valerie Jarrett as a character
she's a radical that's the central
aspect not her race and and so anyway we
get out of this this feigned outrage
from the left and I really think it's
feigned I really think so is the joke
offensive yeah is it mean is it low is
it not funny sure yeah right but does
the left really think that she hates
black people that Rosanna is some secret
neo-nazi I don't think
and the way that I know it's feigned is
because of Kathy Griffin and Michelle
wolf Michelle well Kathy Griffin rather
holds up this photo of Donald Trump's
decapitated head and it's covered in
blood and all of that and then she we
know she doesn't like Trump when she
said awful things about the guy and
she's unapologetic about it
Rosie an apologized Kathy Griffin didn't
apologize she apologized and then she uh
apologized here you go she told us
herself hey everybody it's me Kathy
Griffin I sincerely apologize I'm just
now seeing the reaction of these images
I'm a comic I crossed the line I move
the line then I cross it I went way too
far the image is too disturbing I
understand how it offends people it
wasn't funny I get it I've made a lot of
mistakes in my career I will continue I
asked your forgiveness what was comedian
Kathy Griffin apologizing for her
infamous photoshoot holding the
decapitated likeness of the guy in the
White House she caused an uproar I made
some powerful enemies but she's not
really you know taking it very hard
anymore she's telling us how tough
things got and how she's gonna you know
come through it it's gonna get back on
the road and keep on rolling please
welcome back the fabulous Kathy Griffin
by the way take the apology back Don jr.
and Eric arose I called them Eddie
Munster and date rape
look I'm not holding back I'm just
family this president is different
and I have been through the mill and so
now I'm back on the road I sold out
Carnegie Hall in less than 24 hours the
fabulous Kathy Griffin there she is the
fabulous Kathy Griffin and by the way
how do we know I knew from the minute
she gave that apology that she wasn't
really apologizing and it's because of
her phrasing she said I just saw the
reaction to the photo and now I
apologize do you see that she's it's
it's like people do this sometimes
they'll say you'll they'll say something
awful about you or insult you or
something you say how dare you and they
say oh well I'm sorry
if you feel offended I'm sorry if I did
this to you I'm sorry no you say it's
not about how I feel it's about what you
did you can only apologize for what you
did you can't apologize for us somebody
reacts to that and that's what she did
that's a big difference Roseanne said
I'm sorry the joke was bad and I'm sorry
Kathy Griffin says I'm sorry that people
reacted that way
I saw people reacted that way so now
I'll apologize right that's that's a
huge difference here same with Michelle
wolf Michelle wolf attacked Sanders the
press secretary at Sarah Sanders
viciously wasn't terribly funny joked
about her appearance in person to her
face the left defense both of them both
of them utterly unapologetic the left
defense both of them defends the jokes
defense the sets defends making front of
people's appearance and in the case of
in the case of Kathy Griffin holding up
the Poulet he decapitated head of the
president gives a lot of appearance this
is not to defend Roseanne's joke this is
not to do that it is to defend apologies
it's and it's to point out how
disingenuous the left's alleged offense
here is alleged outrage how do we know
just over the weekend I tried not to
read the news too much this weekend but
I couldn't help with this ones the left
exposed themselves for their feigned
outrage it was over there were these
photos that came out of
immigrant children being held in custody
being in these conditions where they're
sleeping on the floor and they're behind
bars and they're illegal aliens who have
come into America
and they're being held in everyone
exploded with outrage jon favreau former
advisor to the president
excuse me up former advisor to President
Obama said quote this is what is
happening right now the only debate that
matters is how we force our government
to get these kids back to their families
as fast as humanly possible Jake
silverstein the editor in chief of New
York Times magazine editor in chief all
of these photos are disturbing but the
first two are especially awful CNN
reporter hadass gold tweeted the photos
and then but though here's the main
problem they weren't from the Trump
administration those are photos from
four years ago those photos were from
2014 that's from the Obama
administration you had a senior advisor
to Barack Obama tweeting about how
terribly the government was handling
immigration how awful it was that we
have to force them to change it was his
boss that was doing it it was his boss
that was doing it silverstein the editor
of New York Times Magazine how do these
people become the editors of these
magazines editor of New York Times
Magazine tweets the same thing CNN
reporter tweets the same thing and then
what did they all do they all deleted
their tweets that's how you know it's
fake because if it were real they would
have left their tweets up and they would
have turned on Barack Obama it was - how
dare you what a terrible president you
were but it's fake cuz they're hacks
because it's just made up and it's to
score political points when everything
is going so well politically
economically as a matter of foreign
policy on every front things are going
well in the country so they have to
seize on these little little moments and
blow them up into something that they're
not CNN reporter hadass gold by the way
tweeted the photos then she deleted them
then she defended deleting them she said
deleted the previous tweet because it
gave the impression of recent photos
they're from 2014 well that's quite a
different tone from what you were saying
before how office Donald Trump this is
all right but no see I deleted them I
just I know I deleted them just so I
don't confuse you no I don't think
that's true I think you don't want egg
on your face and you're unwilling to
attack Obama for the same things that
you would attack Donald Trump where's
the outrage where is the real outrage I
don't know if the whole story were
Roseanne tweeted this joke that made fun
of true
Reed's appearance and had a racial
component and then ABC fired her I would
say okay that I guess that happens in
America you compare a black person to
Planet of the Apes you're gonna lose
your job and you know that's that's the
way it is but I can't believe it's it's
not disingenuous when I look at Michelle
wolf Kathy Griffin joy read all of those
immigrant photos it's just too hard to
believe okay I gotta say goodbye to
Facebook in YouTube but we have a great
interview coming up from Carole
Markowitz great a New York Post
columnist has done excellent reporting
on New York politics state and local
this awful corrupt corrosive place since
I'm in New York I thought it would be
fun to delve into some of that the home
of Anthony Weiner Eliot Spitzer
Schneiderman list goes on and on we will
get to all of that and at the very end
if we have time I'll tell you a little
bit about my bachelor party but we need
we definitely need to keep that for
after the paywall I think we probably
have to censor every word of it I'm sure
the producers will bleep everything out
it's probably why you might I don't know
if you can see in the camera my eye bags
and have eye bags now that's what
happens after a weekend of your pals
sending you off to eternal marital bliss
we will get to all of that but first you
got to go to daily wire calm it is $10 a
month 100 hours for annual membership
you get me you get the end of clave and
show you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag and
I'm gonna try to take some mailbag
questions before I go off to my
honeymoon
because I don't want to miss you for so
long I want to talk to you I need you I
love you go over there right now
the best of all and I don't have this
right now you'll get the left is tears
tumblr I just have a white coffee cup I
just have a little coffee cup and I got
to tell you folks when the deluge comes
in I am gonna drown I'm going to what
we're out in Australia I lie with a
tumblr blog right get yours don't be
like me get yours be prepared go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back
okay scandalous bachelor party tales
coming up before we get to that Carole
Markowitz New York Post columnist great
writer on New York politics
let's talk because I'm sick and tired of
attacking the left nationally today I
want to attack the left in New York
specifically so I sat down before I left
with Carole Markowitz here's our
interview Carole thank you for being
here thanks so much for having me
Michael so as we speak right now I am in
New York you know really oh thanks so
much it's always good to be back in the
city so nice they named it twice
love New York I'm from New York and I've
noticed something about New York
politics that is pretty strange it
attracts the worst human beings on the
face of the earth Anthony Weiner Eliot
Spitzer Eric Schneiderman the those are
just the big names that have recently
come up and the list goes on and on and
on all those guys have one thing in
common they've worked in New York
politics what is it about New York that
attracts these bizarre callow shallow
quasi Psychopaths well I think I mean my
theory is it's because it's a one-party
town it's so rare for a Republican to
win at most of these positions you know
once in a while we'll have a Republican
mayor when things get really really bad
or governor but very rarely will we have
City Council or any other position held
by a Republican so they live in this
like insular world where their
competition is only other Democrats and
it's a real party machine and I think
they just don't learn to compete fairly
or nicely or you know to really be able
to they don't have to be good people
they just have to spout the right
politics so it's a disadvantage to them
that is certainly true and I think that
that's definitely part of it it reminds
me of Chicago you know these other big
cities DC which just breeds this
corruption but I have another theory on
this especially when you talk about the
state politicians like Schneiderman or
Eliot Spitzer some of those other guys
Cuomo I'm not lumping him in quite there
yet but he is a bulldog of a man my
theory on this is that Albany is not a
very pleasant city to live in so you got
you bring all of these guys they're very
ambitious they're usually pretty smart
they you know they really want to make
it in politics they all want to be the
president and then you send them up to
this town in the middle of nowhere and
it just you know it attracts this really
bizarre kind of mentality that's my
theory on in particular why no three
balls now I want to talk about Eric
Schneiderman in particular so he's the
Attorney General in New York well he was
and he Donald Trump nostra Donald as
I've taken to calling him predicted in
2013 he said Spitzer is gone wieners
gone
mark my words Sneiderman is going to be
next he's worse than the other team five
years later it comes out that this guy
is non consensually battering women he
gets drunk he batters women during sex
multiple women came forward about this
how many people knew that this was
happening who saw this brewing because I
don't think the Donald Trump actually
sees the future I think this is just
word on the street how many people knew
about this how was it covered up so long
that's really the amazing thing about
this and I think it was also true with
Spitzer and weiner I think there were
whispers for a long time about these men
and no one cared and no one acted and in
part again it comes back to they had the
right politics and so even in the story
where a woman was debating whether or
not to come forward about Schneiderman
who after he had beaten her and she was
like well he has the right politics I
don't know if I want to destroy his life
and another woman had friends say to her
you know don't do this to this guy this
guy is on our side and you know we don't
want to lose him politically so I think
that it's definitely a whisper situation
where people did know and no one no one
cared because they were doing the right
political things for them and there's
that just that machine I
remember in New York assemblyman said
that Albany is the most corrupt state
capital in the country I remember even
in my own district where I grew up the
state senator Vincent LaBelle was he was
a hero I mean he was he did his job he
brought money back to the district and
it he ended up getting booked by the FBI
for corruption schemes and misusing
money and all that it just was such a
such a poisonous environment that people
would cover up for everybody everyone
there was an open secret about who was
corrupt who was this who was doing this
to this person in this way and but you
wouldn't talk about it because the
Machine protected itself now I want to
talk about this guy Aaron schwozberg
he's that lawyer who was in a Manhattan
deli and he yelled at a worker there for
speaking Spanish to customers let's just
cut to a quick little cut of that tape
clients at your staff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see schlossberg here and i have to
say the guy seems a little unhinged in
the video he's not being terribly
charitable but I'll put myself out on a
limb and defend the sentiment here which
is that in America people should speak
English and further the sentiment that
assimilation is hard in the best of
circumstances but when you have a huge
illegal immigration problem when you
have a mass immigration for decades from
only certain places of the world but not
from other places of the world cultural
assimilation is nearly impossible and so
I think I think he actually is
expressing a cultural frustration that
is perfectly legitimate he's not doing
it in a charitable way of course one
doesn't know if the people he was
talking about or illegal aliens now
statistically speaking a lot of them are
illegal aliens a lot of people in the
restaurant industries industries that
can be paid off the books a lot of
that's not to undercut that suggestion
still not a very charitable way to put
it the guys should get smacked around a
little bit for it you shouldn't behave
that way in public now you wrote about
this you wrote a very good piece on it
he got his public come up in soup you
know eat this guy's got a temper and
he's been a loose cannon for a long time
but now it's become a free speech issue
the Bronx borough president Ruben Diaz
Jr is saying he should lose his law
license what where is this gonna go what
does this mean for New York politics
right I mean first of all I'm an
immigrant
and I've always been very Pro speaking
English I think it's better for
immigrants but I have to say you know
there's also definitely the sense of
stay out of my business if I think I can
do business better in Spanish or Russian
or Hebrew or any other language it's not
not your problem and I think this guy
really you know way overstepped and even
if he was just again take out the race
angle from it he was just being a jerk
to minimum wage employees and that's not
cool
and so if he gets punished by his
community if his like the place he rents
his his office from no longer wants him
there if his friends get mad at him if
his neighbors don't like him that's all
fine and good and I think that you know
like the New Yorkers are protesting
outside his house with a mariachi band
fine all of that real sense of humor in
New York you know you get things like so
that's all fine but now politicians are
targeting his law license and the thing
is if you or I wrote to the board and
said I think he should lose his law
license over this we would just be
citizens writing to a committee that
oversees this but politicians writing to
that committee is very different and
it's a it's a real case of punishing him
for speech they don't like speech again
I also don't like it's not about liking
or not liking it's about shutting it
down or the government specifically
punishing somebody for speech and it
really over steps and I think that it's
a violation of his First Amendment
rights to have these politicians try to
strip him of his law license for words
they don't like absolutely and there is
a broader free speech crisis in the
country you see people shouting down or
disinviting conservative speakers I was
just into dinner in New York not too
long ago called the dis invitation
dinner for the Bill Buckley program
where every year they take a speaker who
was disinvited from a college campus and
they have him come and give a speech and
you see this all over the place you know
ben shapiro has they have to like you
know take out $600,000 worth of security
to protect against applause he's very
dangerous he's a five foot nine Orthodox
Jew who's relatively polite mild
mannered he's
very intimidating and so you see this
crisis brewing but people they don't
seem to understand there are different
levels there are different issues being
discussed what private people can say to
private people what private
organizations or businesses can say to
one another and what politicians who
have the public trust are allowed to say
about free speech and what speech they
can limit do you see this problem
getting the better in the near future or
only getting worse both in New York and
nationally well part of the problem is
that we just don't teach any kind of a
historical or you know we don't teach
the amendments that people graduate
thinking that it's a violation of their
First Amendment rights if they can't
yell at work for example the the whole
kneeling thing you know in the NFL the
NFL says you can't do it it's not a
violation of your First Amendment rights
go ahead Neal any other time other than
when you're at your job so I think that
people really just don't understand the
distinction and what happens is these
when these politicians do overstep like
this nobody realizes this is different
this isn't just protesting outside of a
place that you don't like or that is
doing something that you're unhappy
about this is a politician stepping in
and telling say a business stop this
kind of speech stop allowing these
speakers who you know to speak at your
place of business that's absolutely
right and it's even just we know this is
true practically because most of what
Ben does at my place of work is yell and
scream at me so if you weren't allowed
to do that I don't know that means the
boss couldn't even come in to his own
office doesn't make any sense really
really interesting stuff and a lot of
times people don't the old we want to do
is talk about the really glamorous sort
of issues the really national ones that
splash on the news but all of politics
happens at the local and state level all
the really interesting stuff and a lot
of what really matters so really good
points I look forward to reading even
more about this case and it's so
important it's so important to cover you
know Schneiderman Weiner Spitzer those
are the guys who are you know effecting
politics just below the surface just
below where the cameras
are always focused so really good stuff
Carol thank you so much for being here
I hope thank you I hope that the machine
in Albany doesn't off me before I make
it back to LA but it in any case the
conversation was worth it nonetheless
that's right you're always welcome in
Brooklyn
so speaking of just below the surface I
guess I gotta say something about the
bachelor party because the bachelor
party actually made me realize something
very important which is that I really
really really want to get married it
made me realize that and I think this is
actually the purpose of bachelor parties
so the bachelor party exists to just
cause mayhem and chaos and degeneracy
and dereliction of duty and you go out
and you drink too much and you smoke
Cuban cigars and you go gambling in
Atlantic City
maybe I'm just talking about my bachelor
party you eat too much steak you only
consume red meat you feel like a
disgusting filthy masculine animal for a
day or a couple days the purpose of this
is to remind you that being a single man
isn't that great like it is really fun
for about five seconds but then like all
sinful things you just get disgusted by
it and exhausted with it
so we had a really good time a bunch of
my pals we went out in Manhattan and
then we went down to Atlantic City which
you know it's like the New Jersey of New
Jersey I mean this place is not not what
it was ever supposed to be and certainly
not what it used to be so we went down
there we had a really good time was
great to hang out with men but men are
disgusting animals and it really
reminded me of the complementarity of
the sexes how important it is to to find
that lady and move on in your life
because listen high schools a lot of fun
I had a good time in high school college
is a lot of fun I had a great time in
college your 20s are a lot of fun being
I was living in New York then living out
in LA that's super fun that's really
good but you can't live there forever if
you live there forever you're gonna
become an overgrown child so you got to
keep moving on maybe that means maybe
that doesn't necessarily mean you're
gonna get married sometimes it's hard to
find people in our swai tripe culture
but it means moving on and doing
something new progressing forward
building new relationships interpersonal
friendship
or romantic relationships going
somewhere in your career reading new
books challenging yourself to move
forward because if you don't do that if
you want to be stuck you can keep just
having too much fun you're gonna be an
adolescent's forever and you're gonna
wind up in a hotel room in Atlantic City
with too many Cuban cigars and too much
whiskey you know you know leftovers of
steak all around you and a bunch of
smelly men nobody wants that forever you
can only hang out with your paddles for
so long so it's really good I really
defend the ritual of the bachelor party
party and I'm glad I'm glad I had one
and I'm glad it's over but before I go
it's no longer Memorial Day it's Tuesday
but we did have Memorial Day and we
didn't broadcast on there so I do just
want to remind everybody that freedom
isn't free and of course we owe so many
of our freedoms and and what we enjoy in
this country and our life here and our
ability to pursue happiness here we owe
that to the real heroes the men and
women who died is serving their country
who'd give their lives for our freedom
there's a classic expression dulce at
decorum asked pro patria mori it is
sweet and fitting to die for your
country sweet and and seemly to die for
your country and in this culture we lose
sight of that a lot we some people
confuse Memorial Day and Veterans Day
there are different days veterans are
the people who fought Memorial days for
the people who died who gave their lives
for the country and in a culture that's
materialistic and that is self-hating
like America is today and like the West
is today we hate ourselves we hate our
founders we hate the the religion that
that gave us the culture that gave us
our politics since we hate all of that
then it doesn't make any sense to die
for your country and it's a strange day
in America it's a it's a day that
doesn't make a lot of sense if you live
in a in this very modern materialistic
atheistic a culture that we have
fortunately mostly on the right there is
a patriotic culture that's been
preserved and a sense that this life is
in everything that there are things more
important than just going around and
continuing to live that there are noble
causes worth giving your life for you
know if life is so who ever thought that
life is
oh dear and P so sweet as to be
purchased at the hands of chains and
slavery that's what Ronald Reagan asked
in his time for choosing speech some
things in life are worth dying for
I'm glad that I haven't had to do that
I'm very glad that a greater men did
that for me and we should all take a
moment to remember that and to think
about how what Memorial Day means in in
this kind of culture and maybe Memorial
Day is a guideposts for us to try to
turn that culture back to something that
makes a little bit more sense and helps
us make sense of our freedom and the men
and women who have died to preserve that
freedom for us okay that's quite a gamut
today talking about bad jokes you know
canceling sitcoms bachelor parties and
Dolce it Decorah messed that's our show
I'll be back tomorrow and then folks I'm
going away to get married and go to a
beach somewhere
so unless ABC cancels my show I'll be
back after that get your mailbag
questions and I want to take some
tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael gnosis is
the Michael Knowles show I'll talk to
you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you